Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch and
uh I'm very happy here to be here this
morning with h Wilders the Dutch
parliamentarian and producer of the
celebrated film FNA which depicts
various verses of the Quran and Muslims
acting violently upon it FNA of course
has
become the center of an international
effort led by the organization of the
Islamic conference to Outlaw criticism
of Islam and so the first thing I'd like
to ask you is what were your intentions
in creating this film did you want to uh
insult Muslims and hurt their feelings
yes no uh Robert U my aim was certainly
not to to provoke Muslims or to get an
international stir or problems or
whatsoever I remember very well last
year first I started by writing an
article in one of the major Dutch
newspapers um about the threat of the
islamization of our culture and what I
thought that the Quran um um represented
then afterwards we had a i initiated a
debate with the Dutch prime minister
about the same issue and I thought well
not everybody is looking um um at the at
the at the C-SPAN in the Netherlands at
all the Parliamentary debates and not
everybody's reading the newspaper so how
do I get my message more clear about
what I see that the threat contains and
what the Quran really stands for and so
it's it's it was not made as a
provocation or whatever it was made by a
politician who of course is I'm not a
filmmaker but still I found the
obligation well to to educate uh the
people in the Netherlands and maybe even
abroad about uh um what the Quran really
stands for and in order to achieve that
um I made a choice not to use any actors
because then anybody could say well look
this guy is playing with the facts so I
used with the help of some of some
people who know even more about the
Quran than I do um I I chose certain um
certain verses from certain suras and I
used a real uh um images um um to
combine with those verses excellent yes
I uh noted myself that the film merely
shows Quran verses and then Muslims in
some cases actually quoting the same
verses in order to incite people to
violence and I thought that it was
extremely ironic in light of that that
anyone would think that the film itself
was hateful or violent except in so far
as it depicts Muslims being hateful and
violent on the basis of these Quran
verses and I wondered if you uh thought
that there was any what has your
reaction been to the reaction to the
film in when people say that it is
hateful and violent and trying to Insite
people against Muslim well I fully
subscribe to what you said Robert I mean
if you if there would be any hatefulness
or blasphemy or whatsoever as part of
the of my short film FNA um then it's on
the it's the responsibility of the
people acting in it and the people
acting in it in fact are Muslims Muslims
doing the most terrible um things so um
it was very strange to see that a lot of
countries from from Saudi Arabia to Iran
from Jordan um to uh Lebanon they all
complained in the most terrible way they
said well this is blasphemic and uh he's
insulting our Islam and Al-Qaeda said
made the most terrible threats to me
personally but also to the Dutch troops
in Afghanistan
whereas more or less they made FNA they
are FNA they made it I mean they are my
actors so if anybody is to blame for
this it's them it's not me absolutely
absolutely do you what do you think are
the chances however on the basis of this
claim that Muslims are being insulted by
this film that the European Union will
act to restrict the possibility of such
films being made in the future well I
think this is a real example of the dud
of the of the west of the European Union
not only the European Union look at the
United Nations um if possible that's
only worse it's even worse I think if we
would abolish the United Nation or put
general assembly in Mecca somewhere it
would not really change so much as it is
today so it's it's it's it's it's very
sad that when it comes to we are not
talking about H Wilders or fitner we are
talking about the freedom of speech for
everybody I mean this is at stake here
I'm totally unimportant when it comes to
the to the to the whole picture of
freedom of speech and this is the first
not even the first it's the second or
the third step that politicians who are
not that brave to stand up and say come
on whatever criticism you can have if
somebody we are democracies if
somebody's acting within the boundaries
of our laws within within the rule of
law nobody no no country no Arab country
no United Nations no European Union um
can uh uh stop um um exercising their um
um um freedom of speech uh and they are
doing that now so it's it's pure dimude
I remember very well when the Dutch
government the Dutch foreign minister
went to the Middle East he went to
Damascus he saw his colleague the
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Syria and
he said well s there will be in the come
few months there will be a movie called
FNA and um it's it's totally we are
totally objecting the content of that
movie whereas he didn't even see one
second he didn't know anything about the
content of FNA and this is even worse
than deud this is going on their knees
giving in giving up uh and this is this
is appeasement uh policy it's like a lot
of chamberlains but then in the
beginning of the 21st century if the
European Union does pass some freedom of
speech restrictions what do you think
will be be the reaction in Europe will
there be a re a
popular protest against this or have
things progressed to the point where if
such a measure does become law that
there would be General
acquiescence well I think it's it's very
hard I think that if the public really
knows what is happening um they will not
like it and there will be a popular uh
reaction however as so often when it
comes to un resolutions or european uh
guidelines and and people don't know and
they find out uh when it's too late and
this process of course has not started
today um you see in every aspect of our
life that um um um the way we give in
the islamization of our societies
whether it's in halal food or whether it
is in in in not talking about educating
our children in some schools about the
Holocaust because we could offend
Muslims when it is that as last week uh
people are almost to death in the street
of Brussels because they were drinking
water during the Ramadan and Muslims are
offended I mean this is this is one of
the many steps that um proves the
islamization and deterioration um of
what I call our dominant um chrisan Judo
culture that should be that should be
there that we should be proud of and
fighting for and uh so I think that
there could be a reaction to answer your
questions however if you look at the
political context in Europe today and
it's not not only the political lead
it's also 90% of the mass media which is
very leftish and very liberal if you
today in Europe This is how far
unfortunately we are gone already if you
today criticize it and you say well this
is because of people from Muslim
countries complain or you are giving in
or you're playing a Dei then you are um
most often labeled as a racist or a
xenop even when you are not so it's not
only only like here in the United States
that people Muslim organ ations are
suing people no it's a kind of
self-censorship because in a way if you
say anything critical about uh what you
are just talking about then um you're
immediately a racist and people don't
want to be called and don't want to be
seen as a racist so this this this this
makes it very difficult for a real
strong popular reaction um um to come
out